[Music]
this week an album of never before heard
jimi hendrix songs was released cbs this
morning aired some of the recordings and
it is pretty fascinating have you heard
these pretty fascinating to hear the
direction hendricks's music was headed
at that time check it out
rolling stone magazine called hendrix
the greatest guitarist of all time now a
new album of hendrix recordings is out
and bill whittaker met the sound
engineer who mixed all of hendrix's
tracks
[Music]
that creamy frosty roofing is good for
you my brother i get lost like i just
lost the music i can't help it hendricks
recorded over a dozen songs between 1968
and 1970 and nearly all of them were
about his obsession with root
beer all right baby i think i got you a
little bit
hey baby
wrap your foxy arms around me
[Music]
arms and i made a roofie yeah oh i love
that stuff
we're hearing the raw elements of that
search
and that's what makes it so compelling
his music just it just hit me in the in
the heart so get yourself a root beer it
only comes down
[Music]
[Music]
you know